James Smith welcome to the show nice to
do this in person we made it four weeks
on tour together I'm tired my voice is a
bit deeper I'm a bit fatter and I need a
haircut it's been a it's been a journey
man it's been good but you know like uh
I was I was maybe expecting that much
time together with anyone there would
have been maybe some physical
appications maybe some strong arguments
but actually we got them very well
you're do you know you're very
meticulous to detail in projects that we
work on but as far as a a traveling and
working a company you are fantastic
sufficient chill yeah just like uh you I
could tell when you're tired because the
airpods go in the ey mask comes on you
have your own way of gesticulating a do
not disturb mode I'm right okay yeah
yeah yeah I think so no you're right
it's been a I'm trying not to talk about
tours so much because I feel like it's
it's all of the things that I sometimes
switch off about when I listen to other
podcasts Whitney Cummings taught me this
thing she was satting that chair a few
weeks ago she said in order for life to
imitate art in order for art to imitate
life you have to have a life and it
explains why comedians who just spend
all of their time on the road only have
Road life to talk about they have
airports and dinners and shows and
that's it I'm trying not to do that but
it's been really formative it's been
really interesting for me to you know
see kind of what happens in person at
these events and these experiences and
well it would be very easy for yourself
to not you've created a comfort zone now
where you have a microphone you have
some uh you know research you would have
done on a on a guest and you have the
routine of seeing that person the idea
of going on the road to a lot of people
is one something they would be very
fearful of it's absolute chaos and it's
just you know unpredictableness you know
you're meeting new crowds new hecklers
new events new flight schedules new air
ports you know like even every day
you've just got the anxiety of your
luggage not coming through from the
carousel so not for me baby hand lug Mr
Hand luggage only hand luggage only hold
luggage is a SC up meant to keep you
poor and late um talk to me obviously
we've done this one but you've done five
10 tours before this what have you
learned from touring in general you've
created content on the internet and
spoken to people through the screen a
lot but then you get to speak to them in
person what do people who are existing
mostly online not know about what the
real world's like well first of all uh
I'm sure you've experienced this face to
face when people meet you in the street
and they compliment you and say oh Chris
I love your podcast you see that little
glimmer in their eye where they actually
realize you're real and sometimes
they'll say it they're like oh you
actually exist because whereas you know
characters in movies or you know
actresses in certain TV
shows the real person or person their
imagination doesn't physically exist but
then when they meet you you do but then
even when they see you online or absorb
your content they kind of know that
you're performing for them so being able
to see your you know idiosyncrasies or
just certain ways that you act or the
way that you would engage with them or
maybe give them banter in real life
whether it's from the stage or the meet
and greet doing a selfie they get to see
like a side of you that they've never
experienced before and it's almost you
would hope is you know quite Charming
you know they go you actually exist now
doing that as like activation around in
different people's towns like even the
way that you would make jokes local to
their Town not only makes them feel like
you're real they feel seen which is like
a really nice combination for them to
have for someone they might admire
online definitely one of the things I've
realized is how much more positive the
world is in general than it seems
through the internet the internet is
very sardonic it's quite cynical it's
quite cutting it's kind of a bit
standoffish and tries to be aloof and
cool you know that's what comment
sections are it's always is like a
this like I don't care about you I don't
care about what other people think about
me and in person see people seem to be a
lot more prepared to be vulnerable you
know we had we had one bad comment the
whole tour one bad
comment uh where pretty much she wasn't
taking the piss out of you she's taking
the piss out of me and um so like the
person that wrote the comment thought
that they were going to get like a a
real big breakdown of how I wrote the
books you know the process of writing
and all of these things the fact that we
called the tour the c-word should have
let off to the level of sophistication
and maybe the amount of vulgar that
would be in it but then you think so
thousands of attendees one bad comment
you're looking at maybe 0.1% being
generous whereas you look at any
Instagram real that you put from your
best performing podcast might be 40%
negative so when you look at that that
comparison between 40% negative to
0.01% it's vast and like you say
obviously it's a bit of an echo chamber
because only a red hot onance are going
to come to your event but yeah it's good
because there are some days where it's
obviously like a real you know point of
privilege to be able to say oh you know
so many people watch my content I get
negative comments but they they go
straight to there's no one out there
that doesn't take it to heart unless
you're a psychopath sociopath like
unless you're literally American Psycho
level like you have to take it to heart
in some respect so it is so nice to be
out there and to talk to people engage
with people and have those interactions
which is what I think a lot of people
that t whether comedians whether music
artists whatever really cherish well I
think that's one of the reasons why they
maybe seem more resilient to criticism
that they get online than it appears you
know some comedians in the middle of
some fural or they've said something
that's cringe or uncool or everyone in
the comment section doesn't like them
you go yeah like that might be true but
Friday Saturday Sunday in some city in
Massachusetts or something they're
selling out three theaters of 2,000
people all of whom are there because
they love them because they give them
adoration it's definitely helped me to
understand how the internet is not the
real world and a lot of the people that
appear in comment sections and this is
the same for whether you're a content
creator or not if you're just existing
within comment sections and going wow
the world seems really negative or the
world seems really cycal the world seems
really whatever it's not even when you
get groups of people together it's when
you get groups of people together with
pseudo anonymity on the internet and
there's perverse incentives for them to
say a thing which other people are going
to find interesting or cutting or
sarcastically good and funny so that
they can upvote it like that's where the
the incentives work toward but in person
people just want to be seen and they've
got an interesting question and they're
around other people that they feel Al
like them or maybe they're alone and
they're lonely they think wow like I'm
in a room with 400 500 600 other people
all of whom listen to the same obscure
podcaster or whatever that I do like
that's cool there's a something I've
done before where
say when you get when you release your
book you're going to have a day where
the reviews are going to start to come
in and there's the tendency for some
reason to look at the one star reviews
and you're like you're like oh you know
I'm trying to I'm trying to build a
great good idea of you know constructive
criticism you do it you depress yourself
for a few hours but then what I've come
to do is go to a book that's
revolutionized life let's look at
something like uh Ryan holiday obstacle
is the way which is anytime any of my
friends experiencing like Carnage
depression loss of a loved one whether
through death or breakup whatever I'm
like I'm not qualified to help you but
this book will make you feel better so
I'll go to that book or equivalent I'll
look at the onear reviews and people are
like yeah you know book got boring
doesn't go anywhere um author's really
Off the Mark or stuff like that and I'll
be like okay when you remove yourself
from that situation and you actually
make it about you know someone else's
book and you realize how delusional or
sometimes even bitish the comments are
because when it's your work you take it
to hot but when it's someone else's work
you go they're obviously full of
[__] yeah so interesting to observe that
well look I got you uh I got you a gift
uh to celebrate the end of your first
ever America Tour which is a Texas
Longhorns jersey with Smith 23 on the
back given that it is 2023 so you can
get that framed and take that home this
is very cool I like this a lot I
actually also have you a gift you don't
I do yeah why um at the end j can you
could help us with it please we will
need to open the door that's fine it's
all right I didn't realize that we were
this hasn't been planned I've had this
planned for ages but I didn't know that
you were going to re put me in a vicious
regifting cycle can we um initiate the
gifting protocol we got three strippers
coming in have we it's not Luke is it so
I was thinking for the future of the uh
episodes in which we' be doing I thought
it'd be good to get you a new tonic yet
you got me a Yeti cooler a Wheelin Yeti
cooler and then uh inside at end you
minder we'll soundproof the door more
time okay you might need to spin it
round and do it so that the camera can
see there etan and then um put your
camera down if you can open it as well
inside I've got you a tour kit a tour
kit so can you show us item number one
PM we've got a three pack of lemon boxes
which are uh size large okay now I know
that you might be from a sponsorship
standpoint uh in in very Rough Waters
you got two water bottles in here I know
you've got your own one that you carry
yourself okay yeah yeah yeah um there's
a bottle opener and someone else in
there as well so the way I see it for
many of your episodes especially ones
you'll be doing local in the area you'll
be transporting newtonic on site now I
don't envis wheel in with one of these
is that what say I don't envis you
rolling in with this but I envisage some
member of staff so you'll be like where
is the
cooler that's cool as [__] man thank you
I appreciate it I appreciate the Jersey
yeah we'll pop that back in there thank
you much [__] hell well I'm glad that
I've got these pants finally that's I've
been I've been biging them up and we
won't go into too much detail because
very intimate details around the pants
yeah just um you know there's there's
not much a man cherish is more than the
state of his go gu whilst traveling that
is true that is true I've been fighting
I've been fighting with gu sweat for the
entirety I heard you say on a podcast
ages ago and I never brought it up to
you all wins feel the same and then
you've said it a couple of times on the
tour as well during q&as what's that
mean to you so we seem to think that uh
you know you get an Uber sear charge
when Ubers are really busy it's like 1.5
times so we seem to think that we get
ascending Uber Sur charges on happiness
the further we progress so let's say you
uh have your first pay slip that's
$1,000 it's $110,000 it's $100,000 then
it's a million dollars we seem to think
that the levels of happiness that we
would acre from those interactions would
be ascending in line with the relative
increases in money so the Thousand would
be the 10,000 would be 10 times greater
than the Thousand would be 10 times
greater at the 100,000 however it's not
that way and even if let's say you're a
jiujitsu competitor at white belt Purple
belt black belt winning a match feels
like winning a match the levels change
the importance of it change so you got
Gordon Ryan best in the world lives here
in Austin when he wins let's say the
most prestigious ADCC final those
emotive you know responses from the
brain and that chemistry is the exact
same to someone listening to this
podcast that starts Jiu-Jitsu next week
and in three months time competes for
the first time at white belt when they
get their hand raised they get the exact
same feeling only if your mindset is
wrong would you deny yourself
experiencing that because you seem to
think it wouldn't be at the same level
as someone else and you maybe starting a
business that you love and breaking even
in your first year could feel the same
as far as a win as far as someone going
to you know sell their business for
hundreds of millions like the wins feel
the same and I don't feel like we're
ever told that we we kind of learn it
along the way and I think a lot of
people can feel like they're broken
because I know for a fact you actually
didn't feel as happy as a million Subs
as you did at 10,000 correct so given
people you know there are going to be
podcasters that listen to your podcasts
that are thinking oh I'd be happy when I
get 100,000 subs and you just need to
remind them that it's going to feel just
as good when they get 10K yeah there's a
lot of uh problems around expectations
and you know there's an idea where
expectations rise more quickly than
reality's ability to deliver that to you
that's dangerous right if you think
that as you become better your belief in
yourself to be even better than current
better continues to rise then yeah each
time that you set yourself a new bar
that is a new minimum that you need to
jump over which can actually mean that
large wins are the worst days of your
life you know speaking to Morgan howel
who wrote the psychology of money he was
telling me a story both about himself I
think but also another friend who first
book amazing success all of this these
great things happened create a second
book second book was an amazing success
but the first one was so Interstellar it
would be impossible you know if you're
if you manag to thread the needle of a
once in a generation book in terms of
sales are you really going to you really
think that you're going to be able to do
that again twice you can have amazing
success but it's not going to be that
one and in relation the second book felt
like a failure despite the fact that by
every uh my friend told me about the
uh George Michael Wham documentary I
think I told you this story so uh George
Michael and the other dude in Wham the
fact that it's just the other dude kind
of shows the way that that relationship
was done and this the guy that was
second had a very different sort of um
relationship with success he knew that
George was going to be the frontman he
was happy for George to be the frontman
he was there as a musician but he was
largely kind of the the backup to what
was going on so they release in the
space of one year they release uh Club P
they released what was the other non-
Christmas song that they released can
you remember you're asking the wrong
person they released one other
non-christmas song and then they release
um last
Christmas over the Christmas period
George Michael
is featured on do they know it's
Christmas that huge medal song with
everybody else so he's managed to get
debut single number one second single
number one third single which is his
Christmas single last Christmas debuts
at number two and is beaten by another
song that he is the singer for but he
feels despondent at Christmas on
Christmas Day because his song doesn't
hit number one for the third time in 12
months it's beaten by him in a different
song but that song wasn't wam like how
insane are those expectations it is do
you know what that if I look back at the
times I've been like the most
disappointed or like even upset it is
based 100% down to my expectations not
the reality of the not the reality of
the situation just the reality of my
expectations so it's a fine line between
not setting them too high but then not
setting them too low because without
adequate expectations you then hinder
your effort but yeah we're we're complex
creatures and I think going back to like
the original question is the point of it
is so people don't deny themselves of
waiting huge amounts of time or huge
amounts of effort before celebrating
wins you said uh some of your clients
come to you and say I lose 10 kilos and
you're like [__] 10 kilos celebrate when
you lose one and then celebrate when you
lose one and then celebrate when you
lose one the same with social media uh
there's a 6' five lad outside this room
laying on a sofa we would race each
other every time we grew by a thousand
followers we would race each other to
type that number so I'd wake up at like
674 I'd be like [__] beat me to it like
and people would part of it died when we
got to a million because then you don't
see it you don't see it yeah so uh like
I I I miss those little wins and
everyone out there thinking it's the big
stuff you're like no you grow by a
thousand that's amazing so people need
to be better at celebrating those wins
that's been one of the most common
questions that's come up on the q& A's
across this tour there's been like some
really interesting Trends because I did
my four shows around Ireland and the UK
then we both did Dubai and then we did
Canada US Canada US Etc and um some of
the most common trends that have come
out are all to do with deciding between
the multiplicity of options that we have
in our lives I have lots of things that
I can do with my time which one should I
do that's been an interesting one but
another one has
been how can I not leave things on the
table in terms of how well I perform and
yet take gratitude in the successes that
I've had and I think there's definitely
a fear out there from people that if
they congratulate themselves too much
it's going to kill their
ambition maybe a few years ago I would
have been on board with that a little
bit but largely now I just don't think
that it's the case I think that a lot of
people that have ambition if you tried
to throw water and sand and a you know
metric ton of like [__] fire
extinguisher on it I don't think that
those people that are driven would have
it slown down by taking a second to
congratulate themselves and give them a
pant on the back and get some helium
balloons or a water cooler or a printed
Jersey I think it's crazy that you've
said this I've said this like there are
so many people that have those
unprecedented levels of ambition but
some of them have them more Mis capped
working on other people's dreams not
their own and we've both said it where
like people like oh I kind of want to do
my own thing but I'm worried I'll fail
and you're like yeah but you're doing so
well at something that you don't like
you know and that's one of your best
insights I think that's genuinely one of
your best insights if you're succeeding
at something that you don't enjoy
imagine how great you'd be at something
you love and even if you do go down that
path and you fail like even if you fall
flat on your face even if you move back
into your parents there is going to be a
little part of you that's like well I
gave it a go yeah and I think that I
know it's again another like privilege
thing to say but I think there's some
something quite cool in that and even
you know people that are afraid to move
jobs people are more worried about how
their CV looks than their life you know
they're like oh if I move now I've only
been in this job a year you're like mate
this is about you enjoying your life not
trying to appease a stranger with a
[__] A4 piece of paper you know yeah
and then when I I went traveling a few
times I was younger and I remember
someone saying oh it doesn't make your
CV look good I would sit in that
interview and go I didn't want to work
anymore I went to travel I had the best
time but now I've realized I want to be
back working I was just straight with
them but imagine saying to someone like
oh I wanted to give everything I could
to something it didn't work out you know
that's actually more of a reason to be
impressed with someone than someone that
left a job every two years perfectly
looking for the next progression yeah I
think there's so much risk in playing it
safe what did you say the you've we've
listened to each other's q&as tell
people about the average American
average American is obese Divorced with
less than 1K in the bank so by doing
what everyone else does it seems like a
safe route but it's not it's actually a
reliable way to achieve a life that you
don't want exactly yeah it that's
literally encapsulated because so many
people are are fighting to do the normal
thing the normal thing is to play it
safe and I've said this right the
majority of people are pessimists
because the majority of optimist people
found their way out of the gene pool
there's going to be some uh you know
absolute experts in human evolution
they're going like enters the chat but
ultimately any single human through
hundreds of thousands of years oh yeah
we'll get across that River out the Jee
pool oh it's not that cold out out the
Jee pool oh it's only a couple of bears
out the gene pool the evolution is all
of the people that are risk adversed
worried about things going wrong and
avoiding all the opportunities that are
around them to the point that they don't
take risks but now we have this massive
Primal mechanism of fear that is
supposed to Keep Us Alive and now we're
associating that mechanism of fear to
really trivial stuff like how does my CV
look what if I ask the girlf for a
number and she says no yeah what if they
don't like my first line I use on Bumble
you know we're using this massive
primitive Keep Us Alive mechanism to
everyday tasks and it's keeping people
from doing the one in the past only the
paranoids survived but in the present
only the optimists Thrive oh just come
up with that but it's true
because given the fact that you can't
predict the future you have to have some
sort of fantasy about how the world's
going to go and that fantasy can either
be negative or positive POS so why not
pick one that's enjoyable just pick one
that makes the world seem a little bit
Rosier and assume that the glasses are
full and this is so wild for me to say
because six seven years ago I was Mr
like still am very conservative very
risk averse all the rest of it but it
wasn't just showing up in my actions it
was showing up in the way that I
perceived the world too whereas now it's
kind of like uh prepare for the worst
hope for the best is kind of I guess how
I would set myself up still in terms of
actions very risk adverse but in terms
of the way that I see the world pretty
optimistic and pretty hopeful uh but
you've got another thing that says
becoming feels better than being car DX
is it yeah well just in case you
repurposed it but it's true right uh
what is it that Drake says uh people
don't want you when you have things only
when you're going there
like if if we were to paint like a I
think it's dangerous to to paint a
finished product which makes becoming
something very difficult the the version
or the idea of becoming something
whether you know that's always going to
morph one day becoming a father one day
becoming a grand grandparent one day
becoming a business owner one one day
becoming whatever it is the the Journey
of becoming something I think is so much
sweeter I even think in martial arts
becoming a black belt the way towards it
is probably a lot more beautiful than
when you accomplish it when you get the
black belt even though it's the most you
know best achievement in martial arts
it'll feel just like all the belts you
had before within three months it would
it's just the belt you know like it's
it's such a weird way of doing it but
again it is that thing of saying to
people the version you know stop for a
second you know you might say what what
was it hosi said he said during my 20s I
wanted to be a millionaire now I'm a
millionaire I want to be in my 20s so
many people might want to work towards
something so much and then by the time
they get there they would just want to
be the version of themselves that was
working the way towards it rookie jaas
as well he said about the amount of
times he presented the office to TV
production companies they declined it
they didn't want it tons of times he
struggled he uh you know went through
all these different phases of his life
and he said if I could trade all of that
effort for the same amount of money I
wouldn't I wouldn't take it I he enjoyed
the struggle getting there so much but
is it only worth the struggle because
there was glory in the
end that's an interesting point which is
you know I could never answer that
there's a survivorship bias of course
right which is it's how many people have
the platform to talk about how grateful
they are for the struggle that didn't
make it to the point where they have a
platform right how many people listening
to this this really funny uh uh boyscast
episode with Danny who we partied with
in New York and him and Ryan were
talking about how
um young kids that want to become
creators are kind of being talked out of
it a lot of the time by the uh teachers
and then you hear these rappers talking
about like Mr Henderson in year n like
you didn't believe in me but Mr
Henderson I've shown you now but he's
like yeah but how many fledgling rappers
did Mr Henderson save from a life of
[__] SoundCloud uploads so the
survivorship bias that kind of gets
layered in here I think is interesting
but the ultimate the ultimate answer is
that Ricky Jas wouldn't have achieved
the success had he have not stuck about
so maybe it's a taale like U far right
tail outcome but if you get rid of that
you lose all of the taale right if you
start to bring that in and if people
don't have that hope every single
morning for over 3 years now I've
started my day the exact same way which
is with element in water element
contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium potassium and magnesium
and it is the best hydration drink that
I've ever found it tastes fantastic it's
super refreshing orange is just the most
OP flavor in the world it's absolutely
phenomenal and it helps to play a
critical role in reducing muscle cramps
and fatigue it regulates your appetite
it optimizes brain health and it helps
curb Cravings they're also the exclusive
hydration partner to Team USA
weightlifting and relied on by tons of
Olympic athletes and and everyday High
performers all around the world also
there is a nobs no questions asked
refund policy where you can buy a box
completely risk-free and if you do not
like it for any reason they will give
you a refund during an unlimited
duration and you don't even need to
return the box that's how confident they
are that you love it element are giving
away a free sample pack of all eight
flavors with your first box if you go to
the link in the description box below or
drink LM nt.com
MW that's drink LM nt.com
MW the other thing as well is because of
this Cult of despondency and cynicism
online the minimum bar that people are
prepared to quit at continues to get
higher and higher right that people will
quit much sooner than they would do
previously this is one of the things
like I I really I really wanted to bring
this up and I really thought it was
important for me need to talk about this
about
how how much like uncertainty and luck
and Randomness and
like uh self-doubt both of us had during
everything including stepping out on
stage like pretty much every single
night that in elon's book at the moment
he kind of goes through a Walter Isaacs
and explains just how hard he had to
work and I think that stories about
success coming about due to incredible
levels of hard work makes achievements
seem more retainable not less attainable
because if it was no hard work you go
well where did it come from just came
from luck oh well how the [__] am I
supposed to manifest that whereas if you
say oh all I did was just the same thing
750 times over and over again it's like
oh well like anyone can do that it's
going to be hard but it's not an
impossible feat it's not some ethereal
out there in the [__] astral realm
like piece of luck it's not being
bestowed by anybody it's just a thing
that happened and sure there is luck and
Randomness on top but I think being open
about the process and the hard work in
the self-doubt makes things that are
incredible seem more achievable I'm
going to answer this in two ways the
first part about the survivorship bias
100% credible but I also feel now that
biases can be used to just counteract
someone's points because you might make
a really really important point that
makes me think oh I need to work harder
I need to be doing more but what you
said might challenge me to the point
that I might now pick a bias to use as a
Nuno reverse card so you could say to me
you're like ah you know James if you
want to have a successful podcast I
recommend you do 500 more episodes than
what you've done and I could go this guy
surviv [__] bias you know a lot of
people aren't there failed to podcast
you know so there's there's that which I
I don't like you're completely right but
at the same time I don't like it when
people use a biy to try and uh you know
explain why they're what they're doing
is not working and the second point is
we had two Lads at our last event who
wanted to get you know do well on
YouTube whatever and they were telling
me this telling me that I was like do
100 videos and they were like cool I was
like yeah but stop that to make 100
videos and he asked me something else I
was like like me you are not going to
learn what you suck at until you do 100
videos and I said out one out of 100 of
those one of them is going to do better
than the others and I said you can now
look at that one and go why on Earth did
that one do well and then when you've
done 100 you should probably do 100 more
videos and I could slowly see it like
settling in with them and ultimately
people aren't going to learn until they
start doing the work and that level of
work for some people is fine for others
it's not but you have to have like a an
unwavering belief that it could work
like you say and I actually think
fantasy is a great word to describe it
in the early onset of using social media
I didn't make enough money that I could
save it so instead I was like okay I'm
going to make a different interest
savings account which depends on effort
not money and that interest savings
account is going to be convincing
hundreds and maybe thousands of people
and that's not hundreds of thousands
that's hundreds maybe thousands of
people that trust me as a coach and and
I thought I can't make enough money to
put away tens of thousands into property
or anything else and instead I was like
I'm just going to work hard to get these
people to trust me and I think that that
is such a powerful tool that anyone can
really do despite the effort are you
going to have a big enough pod to be
invited on Rogan probably not but if you
put in that amount of effort could you
get a small Collective group of people
to maybe come to your event buy your
product do whatever it is you're working
to do chances are probably and again
like there has also been people at our
talks that compare their podcast to
yours and you're like that's that's not
going to set you up well there's no
amount of hard work that can really
bridge that Gap and I think people do
need to become very Centric on their own
journey and even if someone else has
been incredibly fortunate and what is it
Malcolm Gladwell in outliers speaks
about how lucky Bill Gates was to be
born it could be outli could be
something else to be born at a certain
time where if Bill Gates was a little
bit older he would have missed the first
computer because he'd be out working
somewhere else and if he was that little
bit younger he would would have already
been created yeah so then I do think
there is an element of luck where when I
was 24 25 I was at a point where I was
probably confident enough to speak on
camera videos were just becoming popular
on social media platforms uh Facebook
then Instagram came along I came along
at a time where there was a low amount
of creators taking advantage of it but
there was a high amount of users on the
platforms so there is a tremendous
element of luck to everyone's Journey
but if you're not working hard when that
wave of luck comes along who is it that
says luck is where preparation meets
opportunity I don't I think that's one
of those ones that's kind of been
repurposed by every every person now
it's just got J shett written on the
bottom
dude yeah maybe there was a uh there's
this idea called churchillian Drift
which I think I've talked you about
before which is the phenomenon whereby
quotes that are unattributed over time
progressively get more and more likely
to be attributed to Churchill like yeah
it's literally it's a name called
churchillian drips I think it was
Churchill that said luck is when
preparation meets opportunity it's just
one of those guys where you go yeah that
seems about right let's throw it let's
throw toward
Churchill but no I I don't disagree
about the the timing thing one
consideration I've had in my mind for a
little while
is don't assume that something you see
as obvious is obvious to everybody else
you know you seeing uh video creation
well there's quite a lot of people that
watch video and I watch video but there
doesn't seem to be so many creators that
might be to you if you had the wrong
mindset well everybody knows that
everybody knows that so what's the point
in me trying if you look at the growth
of
podcasting per audience over time it is
just continuing to go like that I think
it's maybe last year by a percentage
started to tail off a little bit
but still huge huge
numbers 5 years ago it might have seemed
like oh yeah everybody's got a podcast
you go well yeah but in five years time
really everybody's got a podcast so I
don't think that you can assume
something you take for Grant I remember
dude I I found out about this is like my
[__] hundred million exit not
manifest I found out about Bitcoin in
200 10 no 2012 I found out about Bitcoin
in 2012 right price would have probably
been less than 100 bucks I found out
about ethereum in
2016 price was I remember it wavered
between 1990 and 120 and I was like yeah
but everybody knows about this everyone
knows about dark Webb everyone knows
about like Silk Road everyone knows
about buying drugs online everyone knows
about cryptocurrency and then you see a
bull run in 2018 2019 20120 happened you
go oh right no now it's kind of starting
to hit mainstream and there's still tons
and tons of people but yeah we just
don't have that theory of mind to work
out what is obvious to us but might not
be to everyone else you know like uh
I've never been interested in like bit
Bitcoin ethereum anything like that
still not really because you don't have
much control over that stock like
there's the market sure people have a
good understanding there's going to be a
lot of people that always going to know
more or have better insights to whatever
but when it comes to creating something
yourself whether a business because a
business can be grown with paid ads or
organic effort because you can either
pay for people to see your stuff or you
can do it organically and do the work
yourself then you know when you really
want to go after something you can pause
the Netflix episode that you weren't
really watching anyway because you're on
your phone and you can make [__] happen
you can get your phone out you can
message people DM people get back to
people do a story Q&A whatever you can
improve you can manipulate your own
stock through effort whereas with
Investments you can't manipulate Your
Own St the mercy of the market and
another point about podcasts and about
social media and about video creating
content there be some some people
listening like oh but I'm not a video
creator but you know even now I see real
estate agents I see people that sell
insurance making like Tik toks or
whatever we had one guy come to our
Chicago event who was like M I make Tik
toks with the properties that I go in I
I'm one of the people that watches it
when someone drops the hook of this is
what $1.2 million buys you in Calgary I
know I'm like what does 1.2 million so
like there are so many like when I
started being an online coach people
were like how do you PT people online it
was like saying I'm an onlineer
that's exactly the look they gave me at
first but another thing that like is
really crazy people go ah should I
become a PT and sometimes I think no
sometimes I think yeah but then I was
like although the space is saturated I
don't think it's that competitive and I
actually think it's the same with a
podcast where although everyone's got a
podcast if you want to be one of the
best you actually don't have to do that
much work you need good production good
organization here's one thing for you
one of the reasons that you are very
very good at this is the half an hour
you spend before the podcast putting all
your attention into research there are
so many people out there that do
podcasts that don't do that they're
willing to do everything but not that
and that's a little bit more than half
an hour but a little bit more but H MOSI
says um uh 20 minutes of preparation
adds 20 IQ points so true if you do 20
minutes of preparation before you go
into a meeting so true man 20 minutes of
preparation before you go into it might
not be him this might be this might be
horos and drift I think it was Alex hosi
who once said 20 minutes of preparation
um but it's true if you sit down before
you about to have a meeting with someone
or a sales call or a job interview or
whatever and he's like all right so
where are they from or whatever whatever
and you're like oh you're from
hartfordshire I used to play rugby in
hartfordshire do you know the d d and
you're like oh my God this person knows
it it's exactly the same as what before
we go into Canada we're texting our
Canadian friends going you know what
what have we got oh uh Edmonton is home
to the world's second largest mall after
Dubai right have I got any mall jokes
that I can come out like have I got any
Justin Trudeau jokes or we go into
Chicago and I start talking about the
architecture it's exactly the same it
seems like oh my God how deep does his
knowledge run his knowledge must be so
deep because he was just able to pluck
this it's like yo that architecture joke
is the beginning and the end of my
knowledge about Chicago but it seems
like you've got way more preparation
than you do and it's crazy that so many
people put so much effort into one side
of things but not the other but even
just people rest in inure light you you
can't make your crypto collection shoot
up overnight but you can improve the
level of your research the level of your
production the level of your video even
just thinking that a little bit more
about what you make content about can
hugely have a positive trajection on
where it's going I wrote a newsletter
this week about one of the questions
that we got asked quite a lot lots of
people at the the live shows asked about
how to decide between the multiplicity
of options we all have in our lives
there are more things I can do with my
time than time I have to do them in how
do I choose that was one of the most
common questions and this is from Naval
if I'm faced with a difficult Choice
such as should I marry this person
should I take this job should I buy this
house should I move to this city should
I go into business with this person if
you cannot decide the answer is no and
the reason is modern society is full of
options so this is an interesting
reframe to the Paradox of choice yes
there are lots of things that you can do
with your CH with your time there are an
unlimited number of options this can
make it hard to decide on which option
to choose but it also reduces the
pressure of all decisions if something
isn't an obvious slam dunk yes then it's
likely a better option will come along
soon as Derek civas says if it isn't a
hell yeah it's a no the only caveat to
this is it doesn't work with time
sensitive things like having children so
it's interesting I always thought it was
MK that said if it's not a [__] yes it's
or no which could have been a slight
alteration C cers was the first one to
do it I think do you know where the most
obvious so I love talking about
paralysis of options as being like a a
real way to negate your ability to make
a decision when you go to shop for After
Shave there is too much going on there
is there is if you're in Dubai yeah and
like people come in Left Right Center
like hello Ser I'm whoa whoa whoa and
there are quite literally mate if you
walked in and then there was someone
that just looked at you up and down and
then was like okay h I recommend these
three and you know you've only got three
in front of you it's either yes or no
but the chances for me saying yes if the
options are reduced I think are a little
bit better you've seen Barry Schwarz is
the Paradox of choice that idea about
jeans have you seen this super famous
Ted Talk I'll send it to you once we're
done so uh I think Barry Schwarz the
Paradox of choice was maybe 15 years ago
I remember where it was where I was
listening to it on YouTube driving to
Scotland down great North Road in
Newcastle this must have been this must
have been 10 years ago when I was
listening to this
so 50 years ago you want to buy a pair
of jeans you go into a department store
and there is one type of jeans probably
blue right there's no different options
there is sizes 30 waist 32 34 Etc so you
go in yes you don't have an unlimited
number of options but your ability to
make a decision is made much more simple
now you go into a a store and do you
want boot cut or straight do you want
skinny do you want ripped do you want
bleached do you want them to be uh
cropped do you want them to be full
length do you want I don't even know
what half this means precise L right and
since topman's closed none of us ever
will again uh but the point being
previously you couldn't maximize the
utility in economists terms that you got
from each individual decision because
that particular only single pair of
jeans you could have bought might not be
quite precisely the fit and the look
that you were going for but the the
other side of this that we don't usually
think about is the psychological price
that you have to pay to reach a point of
decision making and that is made way
harder when there's an unlimited
essentially an unlimited multiplicity of
options because in the past a suboptimal
decision was because of constraint now a
suboptimal decision is because of your
error at making a right decision does
that make sense yeah yeah back to the
second point of what you said about
having children having children is this
really interesting thing right and I
think it's almost a plague you got
people that we've spoken about ambition
ambition incredible thing to be riddled
with in life you know a satisfaction
with the norm a dissatisfaction of
average all of these things and that has
a a positive correlation on absolutely
every area of your life apart from the
decision making process to have children
because there is a point and I wonder if
you're in this part of your life right
now where the table feels hot everything
you do goes well every episode you do
you you know like the Goggins episode
for instance y nearly could not have
happened but you persisted you fought
for it you got in there it happened it
slapped it did amazing it's pretty I
think it's the video you have on your
channel it is it's the channel trailer
still yeah and you think oh if I'd maybe
been up all night with a crying baby
would have had the persistence and the
tenacity and the audaciousness to say
what I said to lock that in so now you
create this argument in your head
between the table being hot because in
some respects you do need to turn your
back on the table a bit to bring up and
raise children yeah decide in advance
what you're going to suck at so have you
made any decisions in your mind do you
push it back to an age because Readiness
is a very subjective thing when it comes
to children if you say I'll wait till
I'm ready you might wait until you're no
longer fertile MH so then the second
thing I believe people do is they set an
age but then that age seems to be pushed
back year by year Well if you this is
when I will have kids is usually this is
when I will start to think about having
kids and that is what if the
relationship that you're in doesn't work
what if you decide to start dating but
it takes time to find someone what if
you cycle through multiple relationships
what if your other partner you know what
if it takes time to conceive so so yeah
I think uh whatever the reverse of a
buffer is like an inverted buffer like
start sooner than you think you need to
if you want to have kids probably not a
bad idea but you're right like I do
think about this a good bit and it's
it's hard to say this without coming
across wanky so I'll try and do it
without annoying the internet but the
table does feel hot like pretty much
anything that I touch at the moment
seems to go well and that's terrifying
because it's a very high place to fall
from and it really does it shits me up
to think [__] like everything's so great
all of my friend friend are healthy my
family's healthy I'm healthy
everything's going fine I haven't been
cancelled I haven't stepped foot on some
sacred cow or land mine that's going to
blow my leg off every single month the
show grows more every single month we've
got better guests coming on dude the
[__] q1 for next year is just so
insane like dream guests that I've
wanted for decades are the coolest guys
on the planet messaging me on Whatsapp
like yo man can't wait to get this thing
sorted in Miami or in LA or in London or
whatever but it's a high place to fall
from and that's like really really scary
you know it's the opposite of
expectations it's like you actually got
to taste what it was like to be there
what is it the Will Smith says uh being
famous uh gaining Fame is amazing being
famous is a mixed bag and losing famous
torture it's uh it's I think it's
something that I think about a lot and I
think that I've been trying to I told
you I had that ADHD assessment and in it
they told me I had anxiety and I was
like that's not the cool one I was like
that's not the cool one I was like take
that back shut your mouth and um I'm
with it we like tried to get to the
bottom of it and uh the way I make tasks
important enough to do with them and
spend time with them is to catastrophize
a terrible outcome so this is she was
like this is fear based motivation yeah
she was like this isn't a great
mechanism to be using but in essence I I
kind of there'll be times I'm I'm a bit
tired want to have a nap and I'm like oh
you know you could fall off and no one
ever wants to watch your content anymore
and so then I just build up that looming
anxiety of falling off and never being
relevant and you know even though
there's part of me that almost sees
going backwards slightly utopian because
I could always go back to 15 clients on
the gym floor people be like oh my uh PT
used to be known used to be James yeah
he used to be something now look at him
you know like so there's always that in
the back of the mind but like um it is
crazy that you could think about that so
much because the higher you go the
faster you can fall and it's difficult
because I bet that should you then say
you have children I bet you will say to
yourself wow this is actually the single
most important project on my life that
I've cherished whatever it is I said
this to you on the tour I was like I've
I've got friends that have kind of been
what you know you got blue pill red pill
black pill what pill would you call it
when they've kind of been coerced out of
having children because of climate or
because of you know declinism probably
black pill it's it's a kind of black
pism I guess so I I a lot of my friends
are kind of like oh yeah I don't know if
I'm going to have kids and I'm like do
you have a good life and they say yeah I
have great life and I went who stopped
enjoying their life so you could have
yours oh yeah my parents did how old was
they oh they're about 36 oh so you know
maybe you could do what your parents did
and pay it forward but there's declinism
is the idea that the world's becoming a
worst place and with social media I
think that's ever growing to make people
feel like it is because think about it
right we had [__] pandemic then we
had Ukraine Russia now we got Palestine
Israel like some people on social media
are like I'm I'm too crippled by the
state of the world to James Smith live
tour yeah so like but then women are
better educated than ever uh less women
die during child birth than ever the
rates of infants making it to the age of
reproduction are higher than ever World
famine is lower than ever I'm pretty
sure even I'm not trying to you know
underplay the state of the world as far
as War but when you look at World War II
when you look at World War I when you
look at the amount of deaths that
countries lost to war pre This Modern
time surely you know even the amount of
available tap water to certain nations
in the world the the number of climate
related deaths has decreased by 98% over
the last 100 years it's a 50 time 50x
decrease so we could build a pretty
strong argument to these black pill
Bankers that you know the the state of
the world is getting better and I I
really it's crazy that you know if you
were to say if you were to say anything
along the lines of to stop a population
breeding it could be considered
genocidal but then when it's you and
your own family is considered go you
know you're saving the planet hero I
hate the fact that there's virtue in the
black po mentality well there's when it
comes to not having kids when it comes
to uh trying
to discourage people from having
children around climate change I
think a massive amount of that is
people's selfishness or fear around
lifechanging uh around what becoming a
parent will be like just purposed into
what seems like an altruistic philosophy
it's their personal motivations being
put outward it's called The inoc Citadel
by Ain which is that you basically
repurpose something which is an inward
fear into an outward uh like social
justice campaign
and you it's not wrong like women get
complications during child birth and you
sometimes the kids don't make it to term
and that's brutal and awful and painful
and that is an absolutely honest fear
that women can and do have but saying
that it's because of climate and because
you don't want the world to end and
because there's too many people which is
[__] horeshit given the like decline
in birth rats at the moment isn't it
crazy that even the decline in birth
rate which is an it's it's not a
subjective opinion if you look at the
objective statistics of repop populace
in the US which is where the majority of
the data is from you can literally say
to people we are not having enough
children we know how many people are
going to be around in however many years
time because as it's told demography is
Destiny right we can't make any more
one-year-olds we can't make any more
2-year-olds we can't make any more
three-year-olds so we can predict with
100% accuracy the maximum number of
people that can be around in future
right it's one of the very few things
that you can have absolute accuracy with
doing you see Kim Jong-un was uh weeping
was dabbing his tears away as he begged
North Korean women to have more children
this happened a couple of weeks ago so
yeah I bro there was this I SP spoke
about this with Danny from the
boyscast this Canadian guy had got a
vasectomy so that he wouldn't have kids
froze his sperm though which kind of
feels a little bit like a [__] pull
rip cord in case of children um fro got
a as sectomy so that he would not
negatively impact the
climate then spent the next 5 years
flying around Asia with his partner so
he said it could be argued that the uh
gains that we made for the climate by
not having a child were offset by all of
the flights we took living our freedom
and this is the other side that one of
the most common reasons for people not
entering relationships and not having
kids at the moment is just don't feel
ready or uh enjoying my life too much
basically that there are so many things
you can do right now that are enjoyable
that are right in front of you that are
convenient and comfortable from
entertainment to travel to experiences
to time with friends to all the rest of
the things the standard of living has
raised even the worst type of life so
much to a degree of comfort and
enjoyment and convenience that many
people look at children and say well
that feels like a downgrade whereas in
the past it's like what else have you
got to do 1960 sat there with a book and
a glass of wine what else are you going
to do darling should we have some
children yeah Fu all going on yeah
exactly it's it's interesting like uh
exactly that one thing you know it's
quite it's weird if you were to worry
about men it can come across as almost
like a you know oh something misogynist
is about to come misogyny is about to
appear but I believe and again I could
be wrong with this uh from the
observations in my life that women get
to a certain point where they start to
really think about family they start to
get maternal instincts they start to
even look at children and be like oh
broodiness M I think for men it's easier
for them to medicate their needs with
porn video games so even you look at
something that and again I can't speak
on behalf of women but for men they have
sexual desires which can be fulfilled
much easier via porn than it is via
women so they can have access to more
vaginas in one hour than prehistoric
humans in history which I believe Jordan
Peterson made a good point on but even
if we look into the complexity of male
status men want recognition they want to
be known being good and even though I
was thinking about this a few weeks ago
I was playing Call of Duty and this lad
comes into our lobby to play with us and
he was leveled like a thousand and me
and my mates just start noshing him off
like mate I bet you're a [__] Savage
you know this guy must be sick you know
let's have a look at his KD rati here
right let's have a look at him this guy
is probably like a 15y old right he he
has got a level of status from playing
video games that strangers are giving
him credit then he was an animal he got
20 kills in a game war zone and then I
was thinking this is dangerous because
he probably gets more recognition more
you know compliments more credit more
everything from a video game than he
ever could in his life at 15 and the way
we're creating a world that can help
people especially men medicate their
primitive needs without the need to
leave their bedroom exist in society
even work in some respects you know I
went to sign on the doll when I was 19 I
couldn't get a job I wasn't really
looking that hard my dad made me sign on
the doll bit embarrassing and I was like
Dad I'm not going to the job center and
he was like son I've paid the highest
tax pcket for 40 years he was like you
make your way to the center so I got
there and for the record I took a first
job before I ever got a payout but they
do this thing where they go are you
better off in work it's a legit form you
sit there they were like oh how many uh
how many hours can you work a week I was
like all of them they were like okay
because if you can only work 20 hours
you earn more money on the state than
you ever would getting a job W and you
think to yourself that they're going to
be people out there that maybe are
medicating their needs through porn
alcohol whatever and they quite
literally have the opportunity they're
go why why would I work 40 hours and be
potentially someone of no significance
in you know doing this job whereas I
could have real significance being
virtual world World of Warcraft or
wherever and video games are only
getting better they're only getting
better where there's more cooperation
more teamwork more strategy more rank
you know even the way that social media
was designed to give you the gambling
effect when you swipe down as like a r
uh what's it called in the casinos Ching
variable schedule reward that's the one
I knew you'd know the name for it so
like as we see even gamification of
things online being made to the point to
really tap into human psychology I worry
to the point that as we kind of touched
on before someone's reality in the
online world could be better than their
reality outside of it have you heard my
male sedation hypothesis no I'm I'm
excited for it okay well it's basically
what you've just described uh which is
Mana being sedated out of their
reproductive and stateus seeking
Behavior by a combination of porn social
media screens and video games it's the
reason why we haven't got dispossessed
groups of men going around and causing
riots because they are literally being
sedated out of those things there's when
you have high groups of sexless men
which you do have at the moment under
the age of 30 which is high te High
antisocial Behavior typically there is a
question to be asked where's all of the
incel killings like this isn't a request
and putting a request in with the D DJ
uh but there's a question right you know
you see like stuff like Sandy Hook and
these sort of mass shootings and all the
rest of it but if those things which
they should do would be moving in line
with the degree of dispossession of
young men you would expect to see way
more and what not and it's my contention
that screens social media porn video
games are sedating that behavior out of
guys it's interesting as well I do you
know what this wasn't even like a legit
video it wasn't a study it was just some
guy rambling on Twitter he was talking
about how in the Roman Empire they built
the coliseums to keep the you know just
people occupied you know if they didn't
if they didn't get to see Carnage War
murder in the Coliseum it would allow
their thoughts and their thinking about
social situation and the amount of food
they had and their access to water it
was almost in a bids to entertain them
to keep them occupied amusing them into
sedation yeah so when you look at things
like you know you got the Premiership
football you got sport you got politics
you got social media you got all of
these things it's almost like a a
puppeteer pulling string to keep people
in a state of sedation keep paying taxes
yeah exactly don't look over there don't
look over there keep looking over here
another War for you to be outraged about
oh look at it and it is crazy because if
you were to look at this even the
statistics of how many and of course you
know the lockdown was a little bit we
tempered towards close this if you think
about the amount of people for every law
enforcement officer or every soldier in
the country they're outnumbered vast
amounts and you're always on this slight
precipice of revolt on all civilizations
who especially being America you are
especially when they're armed and one
thing that you know you think about a
lot of the time is we live in a time
where we seem to think our civilization
is perfect and it's going to be
Evergreen forever so we look through
history and every single civilization
before us has collapsed and it's
collapsed for loads of various reasons
which I'm just not well educated enough
in then you look to this like sedation
incel fertility rates rebirth rate and
people are like no no no it's the
climate that's going to get us the Sun
is going to boil the Seas and you look
around you're like which one's going to
go first because if you stop having baby
babies to stop the you know temperature
going up a couple of degrees if you guys
aren't going to chat to girls because
you're wanking in World of Warcraft and
you know if there's more immediate
problems here yeah and well there's a
great book it's on on that reading list
that I released I think it's the third
book down the precipice by Toby OD which
is a primer on existential risk it's
really great this guy has gone to the
ends of the Earth to try and work out
what the risk is of different types of
natural risk and anthropogenic risk so
natural risk is volcanoes asteroids
Supernova etc etc and I
think natural pandemic is part of uh
anthropogenic risk actually which is
kind of strange but then you've got uh
nuclear weapons climate change uh
natural pandemics engineered pandemics
nanotechnology AI Etc and it's like
climate change I think is one in a
thousand or one in 10,000 chance of
ending civilization over the next
century AGI is 1 in
10 uh natural pandemics are 1 in3
engineered pandemics are 1 in six so you
have these things that are orders of
magnitude vvus is worrying me more yeah
well actually the the super volcano
thing is not too bad apparently
according to him he's done the numbers
there's like some stuff in there that's
like one in 20 billion I'm like that's
the cool one like that's the one that's
the one that we want if we want to go
out I want to go out in a supernova but
um yeah just I've been singing this song
for ages climate change is not an
existential risk priority but now we're
going to get labeled climate change
deniers no I'm not saying that climate
change doesn't exist I'm saying it's not
an existential risk priority I'm saying
that there are things that are more
important than that that we need to get
on with and there are ways to fix the
climate that are much more and improve
the quality of life that are much more
important than what we're working on at
the moment and you know that boils
around to actually the very principles
that because me and you are very
different people but we share very
similar values and a lot of our values
are actually because people are going to
go why are these guys on a tangent
talking about all these abstract things
but the reality is that when you come
back to it where we say that people have
more things that they need to be worried
about it actually ties into the very
things in which we are telling people to
become more mindful of which is effort
ambition uh relationships to failure and
the reality of the situation not the
reality of the information they fed to
it like one of the main parts of my last
book was saying to people the way you
see the world is dictated by the
information you are fed about it not the
actual situation I joke about the
lottery tickets whenever anyone wins the
lottery come on Trevor come up here get
up here come on [__] H mate hurry up
we're going to give you a check so big
the bank doesn't even accept those
checks the check is only printed to that
massive bit of cardboard to to skew
other people's reality the bigger check
it must be more important uh Zach your
housemate actually was showing me a
weightlifter I think he cleaned and Jack
like 210 kg and they brought him out a
massive check for $250 and he's like
mate that check must have cost $100 to
make so like when we see these little
tricks that are played by people to
paint the reality of the world around
them such as the big check to make
people feel like they're actually going
to win the lottery we need to realize
that even just a few friends in your in
your Social Circle who are pessimists or
doubters or whatever that does influence
your your reality to how you see the
world I mean you've probably experienced
this a lot since moving to auson right
so Newcastle even if you were to go uh
see your friends at the pub whatever
they they're not on the same wavelength
as to the level in place you're up it's
very hard to have that conversation I've
tried to bring this up on stage and
again that rocket ship analogy which
I've developed whilst being on stage
which is been really cool uh to actually
have ideas come to you while you're in
front of 500 people it's also scary
because you go wow I'm treading new
ground now this might be total dog [__]
but it ended up being okay but it's hard
to have that conversation without it's
sounding like you're making a value
judgment around certain people being
better or or more worthy or something
than other people and I don't think that
that's what you're saying certainly not
what I've been saying on the live tour
but trying to find people who match your
personal growth velocity is really hard
if you're a rocket ship that's taking
off at 10,000 m/s and someone else is
moving at 100 MERS per second there's
only a small while before you're very
far away from them and it's hard to have
conversations about things because the
things that you're struggling with are
different to the things that they're
struggling with and the dreams and the
goals that you have have now outgrown
the dreams and the goals that they have
that's not to say that they can't even
catch you up and then maybe overtake you
in future they very well may do but it's
going to be tough for you to find common
ground unless that person's very open
and honest and unless you are too in
order to be able to do that but you
always want to try and find people that
are ahead of you because they're the
ones that are going to bring you along
it's like show me what is it uh show
show me your friend group I'll show you
your future and I found this earlier on
it's so funny I read literally as I was
in the car on the way here um are we
ruled by midwit this new uh blog post
it's brilliant the people in charge are
more stupid than you basically this is
from uh mackelli in one of his books the
first method for estimating the
intelligence of a ruler is to look at
the men he has around
him if we look at the men and women
around our contemporary rulers what do
we find few reasons for optimism I'm
afraid in 2011 the Royal statistical
Society asked 97 British MPS a simple
maths question if you spin a coin twice
what is the probability of getting two
heads since the chance of getting a
heads on one spin is 50% and two spins
are independent the answer is just 50%
time 50% 25% not exactly quantum physics
shockingly only 40% of MPS got the
answer right among lab RPS it was only
23% most of those who got the answer
wrong said 50% which is obviously
incorrect when you think about it so it
just reminds us the people who are in
charge are more stupid than you are and
the bar is set unbelievably low yeah I
always thought this at
school you know I remember did you go to
I had to go to a religious school did
you have that uh I had to do religious
education a little bit but my thing
specialized in technology so man I I
remember like taking the piss a little
bit we'd be in re as we call it in
England religious education and you'd be
learning like you know feeding the 5,000
like fish the fish the bread the wine
everything the fish that fish story what
was it the feeding of the 5,000 it was
the fish I believe there there's fish in
there I I was always like o i just come
from physics this is [__] be quiet
in the back but yeah like uh was joking
about school it it is like that I think
that uh a lot of the times especially
working in the corporate world you know
it was politics it was who was ass
licking like so many people so imagine
this when I worked in a sales department
this is how mundane the corporate world
is so did you ever work in an office
like have to wear a suit and tie yes uh
I didn't have to wear a suit and tie but
I did outbound Tes sales for the AA in a
call center for six months yeah so this
is this is where the mundane comes in I
worked for uh the inside sales
department of a uh multiactor
authentication security company and in
essence I had to look at the inbound
leads coming into the business and call
them up to quantify them and this
company messaged me and they go we
taking you out for stake and beers and I
was like Lads wrong person I'm like
really Junior Ro they're like now come
up Stak and beers I met them and they
said basically if you come across any
big opportunities It's Your Role to pass
it to one of 10 companies we want them
all and I was like okay and he goes in
return we're going to give you big
opportunities that we're going to close
anyway but we're going to put your name
on it before it comes through so I was a
bit like okay let's give this a go and I
remember at work one day someone came
the whole team come around me and give
me iPad they're like James 300,000 use a
deal that's incredible you know can't
believe you had this phone call I don't
remember it was the other company that
put it through for me and I was now in a
position to go for a promotion literally
from backhanding deals to the same
company that I shouldn't have then when
I looked around everyone around me they
were all they were all dodgy they were
all sitting on their hands they were all
like not really making the calls they
weren't really like working hard at all
and I was like this is it the whole way
up this is it literally like the people
that were in the top rolls no offense
the people there I was like this is
merely just politics between you and it
it is what do you call it idiots the
whole way up yeah and that's not us
being there oh these guys are stupid but
everyone's just kind of pretending that
they know what they're doing it's
reassuring the what that has reminded me
of is the fact that it's reassuring that
you get pretty much no matter how high
you go no one really has that much of an
idea about what they're doing everyone
is working out as they go along
especially if you're doing something for
the first time or if you're in a
relatively sort of pioneering or new
novel industry podcast it's been around
for 15 years there are no rules there
are no rules in podcasting there are no
rules in content creation people are
breaking rules Sam suck breaking the
rules all the time unedited no uh title
and thumbnail [__] like outwardly
boring titles and like relatively
unexciting thumbnails absolutely
destroying the platform kill Tony kill
Tony where four people are just going to
get blasted yeah keep a load of
comedians in let find let's find the
worst comedians that we can and bring
them up like it's there's elements of it
that are existing and work but there's
also new stuff in there that doesn't so
yeah I
am reminding yourself and reminding
everybody that it is there are no
experts in there are very few experts in
a bunch of Industries man I have days
where I do the stupidest stuff I I went
to a gym the other day I me to get on a
a leg extension it was a hamstring car
I've been a PT 12 years right I get on
that and I'm like that was embarrassing
had to I had to do a set to play it off
you know just play off do hamstring but
like I think it's so good that there if
people can show vulnerability on at
every level like even even the people in
the smartest positions make the dumbest
mistakes I think that it's a it's a lot
easier the higher you climb in life to
seem almost un you know like perfect
Untouchable Untouchable unfathomable
like all of this stuff I'm really I
think it's such a powerful point to say
to people people like everyone has same
insecurities same worries yeah well I
think it's one of the reasons
why celebrities especially celebrities
that are kind of in The Independent
Media space they're sufficiently
touchable because you remember when they
came up and you know that they're a
person you know that they've got a life
and you know that they they have a dog
that they need to walk or a wife that
they have to go back to or whatever like
what does Brad Pit do with his day I
don't know he's actual Untouchable stuff
no one's first off he's not saying
things presumably because he's got a
million media people around him going
like don't [__] this up don't [__] this
up don't [__] this up there's a whole
Army of people that require you to not
comment on the Ukraine so that everyone
can keep getting paid whereas for
someone like a Peterson there are fewer
filters between him and his fingertips
or his mouth but also he's in this very
strange and interesting position Rogan's
the same pretty much everybody in
Independent Media YouTube podcasting
world is the same they feel just enough
reachable for people to be able to say
things because they want them to see it
but because of the size and I don't know
where it is I think it's probably about
round about sort of 5 million where this
really starts to kick in in terms of
follow
count people get to a size where the
audience doesn't see them as human
anymore they're not a person they're a
conglomeration of ideas like a
collection of ideologies represented by
a person that is Manifest as a account
and you say things to them that you
wouldn't ever say to an actual person
and this isn't just people say stuff
online they wouldn't say to your face
this is people say stuff to Big accounts
they wouldn't dare say to small accounts
because there is something maybe it's
like uh he'll never look at this yeah
he'll never see it he's got enough money
that he can get away with it it doesn't
matter whatever like that just seems to
happen and the bigger the bigger that
someone's platform grows the more
virulent and mean and cutting the
criticism it and I think that that's
that's just like a dynamic that I've
observed where people are prepared to
say really [__] heinous things about
people when they're a large account that
they wouldn't be prepared to say them
say about them when they're a small
account was it Jordan Peterson that was
saying like 4% of the population maybe
are sociopaths that 1% of that are
psychopaths so like when when you look
at even someone that just has 300
followers right at least two or three of
them are are probably not quite all
there and then you think about uh
malevolence uh autonomy fake account
then you think about people that maybe
get um I can't remember the com but it's
like a little sadist people that like to
see other people upset like all of these
things so then when you when you break
it down into the numbers even a very
small account or small podcast with only
maybe even a few thousand downloads or
whatever you're still now trickling over
the territory for coming across someone
who is just an evil low of very large
numbers thing when we were in New York
on Saturday for Santa Con 8 million to
one odds things happened eight of them
million to one odds things happened
eight times on average in New York if
you have a sufficiently big data set
sufficiently big sample of people really
crazy outlier events start to happen
pretty regularly and it's the same thing
you have enough people that vote that
have access to Twitter that know who
Elon Musk is that know that this
particular pop star is coming to their
Town think about dude I think about this
I think about Taylor Swift more than I
should like admit given that I didn't
think about her at all until like three
months ago think about the security
concerns that someone like Taylor Swift
has right I would guess it's on par with
a president where there's so many people
and they're so motivated such a huge
bucket of people and they're so
motivated to try and get something out
of her and you filter that down it's 1%
of the world of psychopath and of those
1% let's say 1% of them are people that
are motivated and 1% of them are
motivated around she's got an army of
people even after you filtered it down
from 1% of 1% of 1% of 1% you're like
that's still a like 2,000 people they
can't go can't go within a mile of it
exactly exactly Jo's wild as well right
so let's say you've got one and a half
million on YouTube You've Got 1.2
million on Insta um which is which is a
lot but then in the population of the
world it's not massive when you've got
list in this worldwide I still can't
fully get to grips with the facts that
people will say stop you in New York hey
mate love your stuff Chicago hey mate
love your stuff uh even today in Austin
uh Chris and I have this thing where
when we're out and about not in a like a
a narcissistic way it's just ban to like
if you get stopped and recognized we're
flipping immigration getting over the US
border I'm like [__] myself a bit
because the US border is just the
nerve-wracking Place One n and I'm like
[__] but the other person has to be
present for it but earlier on I was in
that um life Organics paying 25 [__]
two smoothies and this guy's like love
your stuff and my first reaction was I
wish Chris was here I was like for
[__] sake I was like uh it's a waste
if you spread a million people across
the world it's not a lot of people how
the [__] are we bumping into them every
day yeah I suppose not everyone's hit
subscribe um we're inhabiting places
that have people like the people that
follow our stuff which is like one of
those but yeah the the on Street stuff's
wild like Zach goes to um uh Rogue
invitation which but you know why it
goes to him because he gets recognized
of course of course of course because
he's he's in that Olympic lifting scene
I don't think he likes CrossFit I think
he just likes getting selfies CU he took
me to one of them and he got stopped
every cor I was like I'm right here guys
yeah that was that was Rogue when when
you went one of the things I've been
interesting in uh discussing with you is
what success looks like to you now
because you've done a lot of the things
objectively sold out Sydney Opera House
like 2,000 people sold out London Apollo
3 and a half thousand people three-time
best-selling author all the rest of the
things but still like I've spent four
weeks with you unless you're an
unbelievably good liar still like a very
normal bloke what what do you what's
your conception of success or what have
you learned about success given that
you've achieved a level that most people
would consider to be pretty high one
thing this year is that I've actually
allowed myself to be proud of some of
the things I've done and it was only
through I've got uh people that followed
me for say five six years and they've
said you've done everything you said you
were going to do I for 5 years have said
I want to get my residency I want to
find a nice girl and settled down I want
to get a dog and move by the beach and I
literally just went D I did it all in
one year cuz I only got my residency
last August so then there was a time
when I completed all of that and then I
wasn't like now what I was actually like
okay now let's keep this up now let's
you know whatever I've pretended to be
to this point we now need to continue
this um so success for me very much is
just about doing the day on my terms so
I love making content love waking up
love helping my clients all of that
stuff and then I just need something to
challenge me a bit so starting a new
book as long as I can get into something
and like get my get my hands dirty with
it that's fine as far as like
financial status recognition all of
those things I don't know if I really
think about it too much but whatever I
every video I I do I want to be amazing
and then when it doesn't I'm like okay
cool let's try again with the book I
have a little bit more time to do it but
really I've actually built my life to
the point that uh the foundations and I
really set and St I can't even relocate
anymore because I have a dog right
people think getting a dog is a little
thing hopefully kelpy lives 15 years so
I've now you know dug my roots into the
ground there but really as long as
everything I do I do to my best I'm
becoming more process orientated than
outcome orientated which is how I got
here in the first place so success to me
isn't about outcome it's about process
if that makes I mean I said this I think
I answered a question on your behalf at
one of the q&as uh where
something that I've always been very
admirable I've held in high admiration
around you is your ability to turn
things into a game like the follow
account was just a game that piece of
content was just a game that writing a
book was just a game and it's a game
that you hope to win but it's not the
end of the world if you lose or if you
just have like an average performance
and it's not a comment on your selfworth
as a human it doesn't make you more or
less of a person if something does go
well or does go badly it's just
information I think you it's really
important to unassociate from things as
being as real as so for instance you
look at your podcast I think that every
interaction every conversation you have
of course it's a great interaction
conversation but it's also a three-hour
stint in the game and if you see it like
a game you can see the amount of
listeners downloads shares whatever as a
score of that game not the reality
because there's no way in Howell you and
I can sit here and think about a stadium
of people sat there watching us do this
conversation right say we get 100,000
views on this video imagine sitting in
that's like one of the biggest stadiums
in America 100,000 people there we would
be a little bit more an edge if that was
the reality of it and I think when it
comes to financial when it comes to
physical when it comes to uh the outcome
of your processes if it's too real it
can become overwhelming very quickly and
overwhelm is a real killer to anything
that you're trying to do and I think
that breaking things down and making
them a game making them high scores is
one of the best ways I can emotionally
unattach from things yeah we don't want
to do that too much right like you know
we we did what was the most people we
did I think we did like 800 people to a
th000 people in Dubai and that's a lot
of people the room was so big that it
kind of didn't matter because you can
see the first three rows and then every
everything else just feels like it's
just three rows and then
noise and there's part of me that thinks
in order to be able to not [__] myself I
have a panic attack before I go out on
stage treating it like a game and
reminding myself that if you can do 40
people in Austin you can do a th000
people in Dubai all winds feel the same
but all winds feel the same but you also
want to be able to take in this
experience I always used this example of
Conor McGregor he got two cracks at the
featherweight Championship because he
fought Chad Mendes as a step in and he
got the interim belt and then he did
Aldo in 13
seconds and someone asked him this press
dude at an interview asked what are you
going to do differently this time that
you didn't do last time when he's about
to fight Aldo and he says I'm going to
take it all in because he was so
preoccupied and fearful and in the zone
and doing the things that facilitated
his performance that he didn't actually
get to experience what he was going
through and there's this great photo of
him stood on stage at the ceremonial
weighin or it might have even been
before the ceremonial weighs it might
have been the actual one and he's got
that tattoo running up his back and it's
just him with his hands out like this
and it's like 40,000 people in front of
them just everyone stood up and it's
electric right it's Conor McGregor Peak
svant artist of War just stood there
with his hands out and he wasn't there
for it his mind wasn't there as he was
experiencing one of the most profound
moments of his entire life but he got a
second crack you know um a lot of people
have got a lot of bad things to say
about Conor McGregor a lot to do because
of the fact he's successful if you watch
his documentary which again they didn't
show the full side of who Conor McGregor
is but his belief in himself is
incredible like and there's that point
where he's like really early on and he's
like uh you know I want my mom to have a
mansion I want my kids and their kids to
do well and he's calls he's like I'm
like Vincent Van go you know I'm losing
my mind and like it's actually quite
inspiring to see someone with such an
unfathomable belief in their outcome but
going back to the point of like I for me
when you do Hammer Smith Polo which you
will one day three and a half thousand
people it's black everything in front of
you is just dark you can hear them you
can feel them but you can't see them and
Darren says this to me he goes he
noticed this quite early on he goes you
don't look at anyone he goes you go out
there and talk for an hour and a half
you don't look at one single person I go
no I don't I can't because if I look at
them they become real so I have to try
so hard because it is a really weird
thing to do you know I was personal
training for four years just
8 to 10 people a day 8 to 10 people a
day 8 to 10 people a day if I get caught
up in the reality of it being what it is
not you know I imagine trying to think
about 3 and a half thousand people
having to buy the tickets wait for the
date get in their cars travel parking
parking some of them got hotels like
this is the hardest thing for me right
say
someone pays for a hotel or flies
somewhere we have people come from
Alaska to our event if I take that into
my mind and actually appreciate that
someone drove 6 hours to come see see me
it makes me very uncomfortable I don't
even like presents at Christmas I don't
like compliments I become very weird
with any uh praise to the point I'm like
oh thanks and they're like you didn't
even you didn't even accept that as
whatever so if I actually think oh my
God someone's just come six I want to
have a panic attack and tell them why
did you do it um we we joked with this
everyone met in the Q&A uh they would oh
driven four hours for this I went I
would drive four hours for this you know
so uh for me I I I like it being Ness
sometimes I like not taking it in I like
not appreciating until it's over where I
can sit in the Green Room afterwards and
someone goes that was good and I can
then
relax otherwise are you concerned about
and you know not everyone is going to
try and do a tour of speaking but many
people
are achieving goals and fearful
of realizing the magnitude or the size
of the challenge that's in front of them
or dampening down their ambition by
taking that gratitude did we not say at
the beginning of this that you need to
celebrate your wins as biggest hypocrite
ever and come to think of it you know
I've been thinking about this I think
it's that I would rather they had a good
evening than I had a good evening I
think that's the reality so when I come
back and someone's like oh you didn't
even you didn't even appreciate that you
just spoke to a thousand people I go
yeah but they had a good time they had a
good time yeah then people go just said
H Smith I'm too preoccupied about
someone else having a good evening then
I wonder how much of that comes out of
fear but again dude we've said this a
lot uh on the massively to do with fear
because imagine imagine the bitter
disappointment that you would I went I
walked out of a film the other
day there there's such a bitter taste in
your mouth when you get in your car not
good and you didn't enjoy the film
didn't enjoy the show or like but it's
even worse when you had faith in the
person whether it was your favorite
director or your favorite actor but it's
different because it's your show right
and there there's a part of you inside
that you know if you let them
down there's no coming back from that I
don't think there's any coming back
remember of the audience that you've
lost forever because I know how much
this matters to you from how much you've
improved over the last few weeks like
it's night and day if you think from ifs
to the the last event wild like your mic
didn't work the other night and you
handled it so well I was behind stage I
was I was nodding I was like this is
good this I was like I'm glad his mic
didn't work it was better because I get
to see his uh you know the almost that
slight bit of being vulnerable but then
you were funny and then you were
bannering with the guy the guy's
[__] himself trying to put the mic
back on you're like you put your like
Douglas Murray voice yeah take it off
you know so uh yeah I think I think that
is important but that's I mean that's
definitely something that I've
considered and and a lot a lot of people
that maybe watch guys on stage or girls
on stage that are even remotely
competent just look at them like oh my
God that must be so terrifying to do but
I've done I've run the live show that we
did 20 times let's say in the last three
months I did work in progress shows in
the in Austin I did my tour I did our
tour and then we did
ifs the skill acquisition if you just
bury yourself in living and breathing
one thing and it's high pressure and
you've done an adequate amount of prep
with a little bit of like existing skill
set is outrageous like how quickly you
can pick something up and again it goes
back to that
people being open about how hard they
work is good I think because it makes
what seem to be incredible achievements
seem much more in reach right I'd never
done public speaking Solo four months
ago and then managed to deal with a mic
stopping in a soldout show in Vancouver
for 5 minutes while some guy fiddled
around in the back pocket of my pants
for like forever and it's just just it's
it's really good it's been it's been
very reassuring been very centering for
me to kind of go through that have you
heard of the inverted you hypothesis for
sports performance and arousal and I
know some people say sport performance
psychology is [__] they go whatever
so um there is like a an so if you
imagine a you turned upside down there's
a certain level arousal not sexual
arousal but arousal you need to be at
Optimal Performance everyone sits
slightly differently on this in more
like a hill for that's trying to think
of inverted you if you're under aroused
let's say I'm like hey mate you're going
to be doing a Crossbar Challenge in a
field in the middle of nowhere and
Doncaster on a rainy day you probably
can't bothered right but then if I get
100,000 people in the stadium you're
probably not going to be even you're
going to be so worried about kicking the
ball right however if you were at your
mate Sunday League match and there's 30
people watching that could be the right
amount of arousal then over time you can
increase that amount of arousal to the
point whatever that you do it right so
some people uh if we went to do an event
there's only 14 people in the crowd you
probably stumble more than if there was
you know 800 because you're now under
aroused there's not a big enough crowd
but there's no way to train yourself
because when a Rous is too high you
become stressed and when you become
stressed you can't think you can't be
clear whatever but only by getting in
the hot water of doing events can you
reduce to a Rous or response to the
situation it's like a what were you
calling it when we're on the road like a
resilience training everything's
resilience training but there's no way
you can replicate the stage without the
stage there's no way can replicate a
podcast without the podcast there's no
way you can replicate talking to camera
without looking at the camera for so
many people they need to realize the
only way they're going to become more
comfortable in situations being in that
situation do the thing yeah same as you
know ice baths whatever it is like
everyone is so caught up about how
they'll be how they'll perform doing
that thing that they don't get into it
and get better at that and there is
nothing better for stage time than stage
time there's nothing better for chin-ups
than chin-ups there is nothing better to
prepare you for an ice bath than doing
an ice bath
what's the future of the fitness
industry got in store in your opinion
because you've been in it for what like
too long publicly way too long but
you're like an old hand at this stuff
now and I think what's been interesting
since getting to spend time with you and
spend time with Luke as well is to kind
of hear the origin story of where you
came from which was this non nonsense
online PT being a little bit like
cussing and swearing and calling people
out and making enemies uh kind of being
being a mercenary Hitman for ideas in
Fitness that everyone maybe thought was
a bit [__] and then saying what
everyone quietly was saying internally
with a few more swear words in there but
it seems like that degree of scrutiny is
now quite widespread there's lots of
people following in your Wick having
done
that where are we at now have you got
kind of a conception of where the world
of Fitness is at the moment
it's a bit of a mess uh social media has
changed what Fitness is and actually
Zach your housemate made a good point on
this last night where Fitness is more
about a popularity contest it's more
about parading your ass in a pair of
leggings showing someone a workout it's
more about gaming the algorithm than it
is about giving advice you think 90% of
Fitness content isn't even someone
talking to you where the the 100% of
personal training industry is someone
coaching you coaching someone is
spending time with them and addressing
them with their problems that's not what
Fitness is now you know oh walk on a
treadmill this height for this long and
you're burned belly fat you know like
there's more [__] than ever cuz that
person just wanted their real to go
viral people just want status they don't
want to help people so much of like the
Persona of my brand has come from real
conversations I had I train this lady
once she was a dog walker and I've been
a bit out there in content I've been
trying some things and she sat down she
goes you swear a lot we're going to get
on and I was like she was like she's
like didn't say I think you're a good
coach doesn't say you got good advice
she goes you swear I think we're going
to get on
so I said to her give me a [__]
honest food log or I'll never work with
you and she gave me the most honest food
log I've ever seen and I was like wow
that's a lot of food she goes she looks
at me she goes that's why I'm fat
James the way we got on was amazing and
I was like the only way I can replicate
that is to be the guy she wanted to sit
opposite from and even in the gym there
was a PT called Chris people go oh
what's he like I go he's a bellend and
people like that's not a nice way to
talk about training I was like I don't
care he's a bellend and then I was like
clients love him my clients are hope
like me I don't need his clients to like
me because they're with him so like all
of these like approaches that I've had
on social meder are the exact same ones
that I've had on the gym floor and yeah
the industry now there's a lot of people
trying to copy each other mate there's
there's a community now probably some of
the top 10 creators in the fitness
industry the second one of them does
something good so if I get one viral
video say about kzer and whatever is in
it the next three days they all do it so
now as banter I'm doing what they do
just to so there's like this little
thing in the industry and then M it it's
getting a little bit frustrating at
times because everyone's just copying
each other it's like an incestuous pit
of lack of ideas due to saturation so
that does make it some days you wake up
but the crazy thing is
like you just have to go back to helping
people with their problems so like
instead of trying to make viral videos I
just think what someone struggling with
today but um people aren't necessarily
getting in better shape and the worrying
thing we actually said this last night a
lot of people can't afford ping a lot of
people can barely afford their mortgage
so they don't want Fitness advice they
don't want to talk about the gym
membership they just had to cancel so
they can keep their heating on this
winter you know the holiday they can't
go on they used to get in shape for so
suddenly the state of a lot of people's
lives have got worse to the point
they're now becoming uh disenfranchised
with Fitness fit Fitness is becoming you
know a privilege to a lot of people oh
yeah it's okay for you you can afford to
go on holiday I can't afford the
mortgage it's okay for you you can
afford to go to the gym it's okay for
you you can afford to do a 12we
challenge and so I think whereas coming
out the pandemic so many people were low
interest rates you know money was cheap
all of these things I feel like we're in
this real rut now where a lot of people
don't care and similar to the inner
Citadel if I can't afford online
personal training personal trainers are
bad they're wankers therefore there is
no need for them you should do it
yourself or so yeah there's a lot of
negativity online at the moment I just
try and empathize with it where I say
okay for someone to be feeling this way
they must be having a pretty must be
having a pretty tough time at the moment
yeah that's a really nice reframe that's
a beautiful reframe around things I
remember um Aaron one of my friends that
I play pickle ball with he's uh Aaron
Rogers chief of like creative chief of
performance now which given that he's
snapped in ailles is probably not that
fun we were playing pickle ball at the
courts next to mine and we had a speaker
on just listening to some of his like
weird tribal [__] dubstep stuff
there's a lady over the far side with a
dog who starts shouting about the fact
that this is a park this is a park and
it's supposed to be quiet the fact that
she's shouting obviously kind of made it
a little bit funny uh and I would have
gone over me people pleaser would have
gone over and just turned the music down
Aron went over and turned the music up
and started shouting that he couldn't
hear her um but my where I went after
that given the fact that he' done
something that ostensibly was more rude
right to this lady that was shouting
from 100 yards away about the fact that
you should have been peaceful uh when we
finished up I was more vicious about her
I was like like that [__] [__] like
you know like what does she think she's
doing like what an idiot blah blah blah
his first place to go to
was imagine how bad her life must be
that she feels the need to kick off
about two people playing a sport and
listening to music at quite a quiet
volume that you can barely hear from 50
yards away or 100 yards away and that's
that's something I don't know getting
over like bitterness or resentment or
like being cutting on mean in response
to things is uh it's pretty noble like
approach man I was flying back from
Dubai in maybe maybe
2016 and the lady next to me was a big
lady but it was okay she had her seat I
had my seat but she couldn't get a tray
down for a food so she had to ask if it
was okay to use my tray to eat her food
and I said yeah that's completely fine
whatever she did it and as I was going
to the toilet the aost said to me like
I'm sorry about that and I remember
saying to her I was like if you think
that was uncomfortable for me imagine
how comfortable that was for her yeah
yeah and she was like oh she she had
really clocked it for a second and I was
like that's one thing I've really been
trying for a long time and I actually
even if someone's super negative on a
comment now sometimes I go hey bro you
must be in you must be having a tough
day hope you say to someone in the
comments I hope your situation improves
Zach uh rep appes to those ones with get
well
soon what you know get well soon you
know some people like uh this is so
there are people oh that's really nice
James and then there's the other side of
me that if you abuse people in the
comments they can report it or get it
deleted or whatever but I've come to
find that you know you can you can just
say to someone like um yeah hope hope
you get well soon there's no way they
can report that that's not abusive
nothing like that ah I hope your
childhood trauma resolves itself soon I
hope you regain your man it's true the
people that so motivated to say super
mean things on the Internet it's an
indicator that there's a lot of things
that aren't going right in their life
outside of that if someone's life is
obsessed with politics or obsessed with
drama or obsessed with culture wars or
obsessed with whatever you are
compensating for not having any control
somewhere else in your life and the
first sense that you should
feel after you get rid of the
indignation and the sort of mocking
sense of superiority should be
empathy it's like oh my God imagine how
bad your life must be if you're focused
on this you know in like 2014 I emailed
Joe Wix and I said to him like I was
gunning him a lot online but again his
fans loved him and at the time I said I
sent him an email and I said you never
get put down by people above you and
life I just rest him me short of that I
said to him hey mate I've got 13,000
followers you know I need this you know
like it's like you know like when
rappers go head tohe be they need beef
so I I just let him know early on I'm
pretty sure responded as well I was like
look mate and I don't think he cares
he's in his millions of pounds house
he's got his all of this stuff and like
the same goes that yeah you you never
get criticism from people above you and
I think that speaks volumes I've
messaged this to so many creators who
are getting getting [__] or they're
trying to explain themselves online or
they're trying to get counseled you
never get [__] on from above bit like
the layer cake mhm So like um I think
that's just a good realization for a lot
of people that when they're getting
criticism or like when people are really
going in on them it's very rarely from
people above them you made a series of
enemies during your ascendency Jo Wix
keto
veganism body you had a crack at
bodybuilding for a while well you know
why because bodybuilders don't use my
services so but no bodybuilder no
competitive bodybuilder needs yeah no
competitive bodybuilder is going to buy
my book no competitive bodybuilders is
going to respect me as a coach because
they're probably in better shape than me
they're probably almost test than me so
if you're ever going to go after someone
go after someone who is never ever going
to benefit your life would you advise it
as a growth strategy now yeah it's good
because would you you I'm not alienating
them for who they are I'm alienating
their values that don't correlate with
the values of the people that I'm trying
to help because the biggest mistake
people make in Fitness advice is
realizing that they are not their client
so I said there's so many pts you're not
your client you know your client doesn't
want to eat chicken and broccoli your
client doesn't want a sixpack they've
told you they want a sixpack cuz they're
telling you what they think they want
you to hear my clients will come to me
go I want a six I'm like no you don't
tell me what you want okay cool so you
want to fit in the dress that you fit in
3 years ago that's very different to a
six-pack especially for a woman you know
then guys are like I I want big pecs and
I'm like send me a picture of yourself
topless and I'm like whoa Let's Lose
let's use 30 let's get you running a 5k
without killing yourself then let's talk
about pecs you know like so many people
communicate in the wrong ways so
bodybuilders like okay fasted cardio
half an hour in the morning I'm like bro
that's great for bodybuilders who are
already on the lowest amount of calories
they're already on the most amount of
whatever whatever even little things
like the the mentality of a bodybuilder
is so different to the mentality of a
normal person so if I can pick holes at
that as far as a growth strategy people
then feel seen so you know even in like
the smartest marketing where you can
drill in someone's problems you say to
someone hey do you want to learn how to
lose fat without doing 30 minutes of
fasted cardio in the morning or whatever
it is you can communicate with the
people you want whilst expressing a
message to the the shagrin you said this
way the other day of bodybuilders did I
use that right Sharin shagin much to the
shagin yes yeah shagin yeah so there you
go shagin so uh yeah it's it is a growth
strategy because you need to alienate
the things that people have wrong and
some people do want to look like
bodybuilders but the majority of my
clients don't and I don't offer extreme
deficits I don't offer fasted cardio I
don't offer getting people ready for
show and the main reason is the values
thing because in every sport on the day
you compete you should be
physiologically and psychologically your
best however when it's down to
bodybuilding and physique the day you
compete you're physiologically and
psychologically your worst that's a mass
I'm like why are we epitomizing that as
Fitness when it's clearly not Fitness
what do you think is the future of the
fitness industry what would you predict
for the next five years or so any trends
that you can see growing or falling
away have I Got Time time we well we're
going to finish in five minutes okay
have we got enough have we got five
minutes in you yeah yes are you sure
you've been holding it I'm sorry I know
it
hurts um future of the fitness
industry I think the the bodybuilding
stuff is starting to desate a little bit
but we still have this massive wave of
dishonesty and it is Led unfortunately
by a lot of brand deals now you have
brand deals with companies that you
actually value I I know for well like I
see you having your ag1 every day having
your lmnt like you're not a the people
are oh Chris likes ag1 I I personally
don't but like I actually see it
something that you you cherish and use
and you're very transparent with people
with your blood work he all this stuff
but if you're in the fitness industry
not the podcast industry suddenly the
ethical standpoint of let's say
testosterone if you can go on test and
not tell people that benefits your brand
it benefits your programs it benefits
everything in that little ecosystem of
of monetary value so
I would love for that dishonesty to
desate I feel like it slightly kind of
is but then it also slightly kind of
isn't but I think that people are
clowing up to the BS a bit more now
evidence-based stuff seems to be coming
more to the Forefront like your mic
israels of the world seem to be in a a
pretty big ascendency right now um but
then there's a lot of ideological people
where we've got people in people real if
you go to a supermarket and pick
something up off a shelf that's your
hook and it's a very effective hook cuz
people like oh what's going on here you
know what's going on why is this going
to Super so now any person in the
supermarket chat and Waffle picking
something off a shelf and going this is
[__] suddenly people are like oh why why
is it you know so we've got all of these
people chat and waffle in supermarkets
Kale's bad for you fastings you know
going to stop you ever getting Cancer
all of these things and now people are
just in this there's a lot of
ideological stuff and you know veganism
had its wave carnivore is is actually
still alive because of Joe Rogan and I
said you before for I wish it wasn't as
good as it was when I was on it I felt
great uh few explosive shits but you
know uh ideology is still pretty Rife
and uh unfortunately a lot of people in
a bid to remain active on social media
to get views on social media because
views and interactions on social media
is how people are obtaining the levels
of self-proclaimed status status is what
all of us are trying to get drunk off
you know the recognition of you having a
standup comic come to your live show and
say you were great on stage doesn't
change your bank account it makes you
feel [__] good because of the levels
of status you've attained from getting
better at that thing so so many people
now getting their first taste of status
on Tik Tok social media whatever and
they're doing it through being extreme
being ideological and by tapping into
people's pre-existing beliefs that often
aren't true we spoke about this while we
were away I never thought of this before
but Tik Tok is one of the most
egalitarian platforms follow account on
Tik Tok means less than it does anywhere
else you put a great Tik Tok out and it
just feeds the for you page and the the
algorithm sends it to the moon which
means I
wonder whether more people will go viral
over the next 5 years than ever have
before through Tik Tok do you have the
opportunity of not being a big Creator
but you can do the right thing at the
right time or even the wrong thing at
the right time and it just explodes and
I wonder how many people that's going to
dangle the carrot of Fame and status in
front of how many people are going to
start chasing that thing and I wonder
what the second third fourth order
effect of that will be have you ever
heard of nicardo avocado of course I
have Ginder bogle's audience capture uh
article about him is the best thing I've
ever read exact like that's almost where
I see it like not to have a go at the
guy but it was mukbang right people like
to watch other people eat onl and then I
I haven't seen his blood work and I
could be incredibly fat phobic here but
he's gone from relatively healthy
looking skinny vegan violin player to
someone that wears a c CPAP yeah he's
gotten to the front man of this you know
probably endorsing CPAP so like watching
someone
literally send their health off the
rails in a bid for views here is like
the canary in the mind of where I think
social media is going to go like
whenever there's a fight phones come out
before people break it up you know you
even see when something really bad
happens people's reaction is if I film
this it will go on Tik Tok so that's the
despair loop I see that goes with it
where people actually are more inclined
to try and go viral from a situation
then help let's say someone has a heart
attack in the street what's going to
happen first filming or helping so I
worry about that because if people just
get Thrills from engagement that can
create quite a negative thing because
negative news is typically what trends a
lot faster than you know positive things
although I do love a good story where
someone like adopts a dog from turkey
and brings it home soldiers coming home
from war to dogs man that's my that's my
[__] Vibe look James Smith ladies and
gentlemen James I really it's been
awesome man the last four weeks I really
appreciate your guidance and your
encouragement since I've been going out
on stage
where should people go what do they
expect of you 2024 what's coming up I
wish I could answer that more uh
honestly myself just going to be trying
to improve everything you know
everything I do to try and get a bit
better white belt mentality you're
always a white belt in everything you do
so uh yeah whether that's books events
whatever the drink which we didn't even
mention didn't even mention it which I
think is quite cool at the same time
well it's just part of our Lives now
right like we don't really think about
it that much also don't have any stock
so might be a part might be might be one
of the contributing factors uh where do
you want people to go YouTube James
Smith just type in James Smith wherever
you like to absorb content and just
before we finish like this podcast I
first came on it what four years ago uh
you were doing it from your bedroom you
had some cool funky lighting to see how
far this podcast has grown over the last
few years it's incredible I I wonder
where it will be the next time we sit
down and talk on it exciting times James
I appreciate you thanks man thank you if
you enjoyed that episode then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subsscribe